[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we're going to be discussing the
appearance of Lord Voldemort and the
very different look that he nearly ended
up having now when the film's first
start up Voldemort doesn't have his body
back yet
thanks Potter's because of this we see
him sort of awkwardly shift from one
form to the next transitioning from wisp
to a face on the back of quirrell's head
to a rudimentary form and then finally
into the form that we are all accustomed
to but what a lot of people don't know
is that for one of Alden warts earliest
forms the one where he possesses and
shares ahead with Quirrell the makeup
and props departments personally had
very different plans for his appearance
let's kick things off by looking at
Voldemort appearance and the
Philosopher's Stone a form he achieved
thanks to the possession of coral the
following excerpt from the book
describes Harry's reaction to the
initial unveiling of Voldemort's look
petrified he watched his quill reached
up and began to unwrap his turban what
was going on the turban fell away
Quarles head looked strangely small
without it
then he turned slowly on the spot Harry
would have screamed but he couldn't make
a sound where there should have been a
back to crows head there was a face the
most terrible face Harry had ever seen
it was chalk white with glaring red eyes
and slits for nostrils like a snake
it whispered now the first thing worth
mentioning about this hideous form of
Voldemort is that it was played by a
different actor which had Bremen which
for obvious reasons made him look
different the second thing worth
mentioning is the inconsistency between
the film adaptation and the book where
the book describes Voldemort as having
glaring red eyes the film version shows
Voldemort with a very different by color
I can't quite make it out
at least with this portrayal of his
character but it definitely isn't
glaring red next the book describes him
as having slits four nostrils the film
adaptation falls short here once again
showing Voldemort to have a full nose
with regular looking nostrils and lastly
the book states that his face is chalk
white this was decently done by the film
but could have been better
chalky ER overall I was basically
satisfied with the way that Voldemort
looked in that film but felt that there
was definitely room for improvement
he was certainly creepy looking but the
most terrible faith's harry had ever
seen surely we should have been given
something scarier if only if only there
was an alternate prop that they could
have used to portray Voldemort oh wait
there is one I present to you the design
for the prop made for the Voldemort
Quirrell head that never got any screen
time now if this isn't the most terrible
face you've ever seen in Harry Potter
but I don't know what films you've been
watching this thing gives Fenrir
Greyback
a run for his money what you're looking
at is the alternate design for the Dark
Lord something that they actually almost
used in the films fortunately for your
childhood bedsheets they went with the
other designs but it's interesting to
imagine this being used in the films
starring children across the world
rendering them unable to sleep ever
again what this photo reveals is that
Voldemort was originally intended to
have much more of a monstrous appearance
complete with animalistic features sharp
teeth glaring eyes and something that
represents creature far more than men
funnily enough this design actually much
more closely resembles the books
depiction of Voldemort character so I
wonder why they didn't just roll with it
perhaps film just wasn't ready for such
traumatic experience overall I'm happy
with the direction that they went with
fines and prefer to the Brehme Voldemort
but still feel that it could have been
improved upon perhaps a half way between
the proposed prop design and the
finalized version of finds depiction of
Voldemort that we see on screen what do
you guys think
which Voldemort would you have preferred
to see the one that they actually used
or the design that was left to pick up
dust let me know down in the comment
section below until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]